let's face it i mean we've had some of
the best players in the history of the
nfl play for us and players want to play
with them you know players want to play
with lamar jackson you know i i really
do kind of laugh at the notion that
players don't want to come here and play
with lamar because
he's one of the very best young players
in the nfl
and we've got a lot of other young
players as well that fit that criteria
so i think it's a great place to play i
think people want to play here i think
it's a team that's positioned well for
the future it's not all about getting
the quote number one receiver that
everybody likes to talk about
we will certainly look at that
we would try to upgrade every single
position on this football team this off
season if we can
based on the parameters of what we have
to work with draft pick-wise money-wise
and all the other challenges associated
with building a football team
like eric decosta gm of the ravens great
at what he does said what he had to say
the bottom line is they're not going to
attract guys there who want to catch the
football until they prove to people that
they are going to throw the football
more than they do it's that simple no
one wants to go and block for lamar
jackson no one wants to go and say hey
i'm buddies with lamar jackson they want
to go and advance their career by
catching the ball that's why stefan
diggs wanted out of minnesota he wanted
to catch the ball more and that's okay
but the reality is good luck attracting
high-end receiving free agent talent if
you don't have an offense that is fully
diversified and entails throwing the
football to the guys who want to catch
it chris no i mean i agree with you mike
i mean first off like i
agree with like just about everything
eric de costa said there i think players
you know nfl players everything like
that yes they want to go to baltimore
and play with lamar jackson no doubt
about it but that doesn't mean receivers
do like you're talking about that's
that's the difference yeah that's a
special culture there everybody knows
how special lamar is you know people
want to go there you know there's the
you know yanik and gawkway we saw how
happy he was there to be a part of lamar
jackson the ravers colleeus campbell
same thing you know earl thomas he had a
chance you know he goes there last year
so people want to go there but it's the
receiver thing that's the issue and i'm
with you i don't think
i i mean
i don't know
like yes i don't think a big time
receiver is going to sign there unless
they are offered significantly more from
baltimore i do think it's something
they're going to have to do through the
draft or kind of get guys that are under
the radar uh bargains where hey these
teams didn't want them but we think
you're really good come here it's going
to be those type of guys until you see
like you said better stats more
receptions more wide receiver
involvement the stats we just show right
there that's the playoffs included
i mean the leading receivers got 69
receptions yeah the de'andre hopkins of
the worlds are not going to want to go
play for an offense like that
necessarily well and then your young
guys if you do draft them like a
hollywood brown
why would you sign an extension if
you're hollywood brown that's going to
be play it out and go somewhere else so
they're going to use the franchise tag
to justify that kind of investment
financially in a guy that they don't get
full use out of because they don't throw
the football they just draft somebody
else i mean that's what will happen
they'll draft young receivers they'll
rely on them when their contracts expire
they'll leave and it'll be lather rinse
repeat that's going to be the story of
the lamar jackson career in baltimore
unless and until they truly do develop a
passing game because guys guys aren't
going to want to say i want to be part
of the winning culture in baltimore i
want to be part of this organization i
want no they're going to say receivers
are going to say i want to go somewhere
i can have all those things and
the football comes my way more
frequently right well and and they can
do that there in baltimore i mean they
can listen if you're open lamar can hit
you there's no doubt about that he's got
all the tools necessary to be a really
effective passer we've seen him get
better every year the offense needs to
help him out a little bit and they need
within that offense yes if they want to
help you know remedy this problem and
things like that
they got to continue to show
that they can it doesn't always have to
be a hundred receptions
but if you're going to be hollywood
brown and have 58 receptions in the
regular season regular season okay then
he can't go the whole regular season
with only like one rushing attempt you
got to find other ways to get the guys
the ball right to make them feel part of
the offense and things like that so that
is something they're gonna have to
figure out and i think we both agree
their their passing offense has to grow
for them to make a run in the playoffs
to begin with but i love lamar jackson
and i we both agree he should be paid
like one of the top quarterbacks in
football this offseason at least that's
what i think i think you think that
we saw them incorporate more hollywood
brown into the playoff win over the
titans you know you need that creativity
yeah there's been some pressure on greg
roman steve smith called for the ravens
to fire greg roman and install an
offensive coordinator who will open
things up for lamar jackson and i agree
with you he he deserves to get paid
it's not the ideal year to do it we
talked recently about how baker mayfield
and lamar jackson are both along with
josh allen in this window now where they
can get new deals but mayfield making so
much more as the first pick in 2018
jackson making so much less as the last
pick in round one
um
it's it's it's a tough
problem for the ravens this year because
the salary cap is expected to be in the
range of 180 million when do you break
the bank for lamar jackson and how much
of that injury risk do you take off the
table because that's the big issue with
him you know when he became the starter
there were people who were like hey this
is going to be fun while it lasts and i
think a lot of people are amazed it's
lasted as long as it has
it's amazing you have to and and so at
what point do you say okay this is a guy
who just is built in a way that he's
going to be able to deal with it he's
not going to get injured like other
mobile quarterbacks would or do you say
well you know what's going to happen the
minute we give this guy huge money
that's when the wheels are going to
start to come off well that's going to
be on them to
they're the one in person seeing the guy
and they know the guy they get to see
him on the field
i i mean the one what we can say to this
point
is he hasn't been hurt
and
correct me if i'm wrong but we've never
even seen him roll around on the ground
he's never even rolled around on the
ground like oh this hurts for a second
before i get up i mean he's always just
pops right back up and there's only been
a few times where i really feel like
people have gotten real big hits on him
or anything like that through his three
years so far so
uh yes that is the risk with this type
of running back certainly but i think
through three years he's proven he's
pretty damn good at taking care of
himself
and at some point we saw this with steve
young we saw this with steve mcnair you
have to transition away that's right if
you want to play at a high level deep
into your 30s tom brady's getting it
done at 43
not because he's running around but
because he's stationary and he's taking
advantage of his arm and so to have that
long career and we've talked about will
quarterbacks be able to extend their
careers into the 40s they will
but
you you're going to have to understand
that you got to work within the
boundaries of mobility that necessarily
will decrease although who knows
20 years from now with the advances in
training and the guys who are spending
all their time seven days a week 24
hours a day thinking about it working
out constantly turning their bodies into
this this machine that can keep going
and going maybe lamar jackson will
preserve his mobility beyond the age of
40. either way the ravens want to keep
him around and at some point they surely
will figure out
a contract that keeps him there the
question is can they figure out the
offense that allows them you know we've
talked about some of these teams that
are just kind of like bumping up against
the ceiling the ravens have a ceiling
well everybody in the afc has a ceiling
it's called the kansas city chiefs but
what do you do to bust through that
ceiling yeah well i i mean i i think you
you said it
it is kind of
the offense going to that next phase of
being able to
be a little more diverse
scare you
with you know a precision pass game an
explosive pass game that you're worried
about whoa we we got to play this
defense because they could throw it over
our heads and now the pulling guards and
jk dobbins have even a bigger effect but
that that to me for a team that's still
in its super bowl window and still very
talented is is the one thing that needs
to be adjusted you know going into 2021.
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports